والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي من
بعده واعلموا عباد الله ان الله تعالى
امرنا بامر بدا فيه
بنفسه وثنى
بملائكه
قدسه وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالم جنه
وانسه وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر
نبينا وتفهيما لنا
وتعليما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا تسليما
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد كما صليت على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال
سيدنا ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد وبارك على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد كما باركت
على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال سيدنا ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد
مجيد مكمل علوم الاولين
والاخرين مولانا ومولى الثقلين ابي القاسم
ابي الزهراء
محمد فيا ايها الراجون شفاعته اكثروا من
الصلاه والتسليم عليه فان صلاتكم نور على
الصراط حين تمرون
س الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏andes could
not for
your how could
سهل الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏ine and
life obed and worship help us
appreciate the beauty of Allah's
creation without disobedience
[Silence]
الجميل الله سبحانه وتعالى
الجميل
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
فطره
توحيد الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏was
and prop understanding
of
the
not
to be
[Silence]
‏is
los peace and beuty
areosely linked in the heart of a
believer
الله سبحانه
وتعالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
شيطان
فطره رضي الله عنهم
اجمعين ابن مسعود رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
[Silence]
وسلم صلى الله عليه
اللهم
[Silence]
سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا تحصوها
‏love
for
gentleness
trueration
generity
colage
meditation modesty and humility
and of bey
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
[Silence]
امام علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله
عنه engel
[Silence]
‏All
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم صلى الله عليه
الله
‏us
and seek your forgiveness for myself for
you my par and all
كلمتي
اللهم ارنا الحق حقا وفقنا اتباعه امين
وارنا الباطل باطلا ووفقنا اجتنابه امين
اللهم وفقنا للعمل بكتابك امين وسنه نبيك
امين صلى صل الله تعالى عليه وسلم اللهم
من اراد بالمسلمين سوء فاجعل دائره السوء
تدور عليه اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب
علينا وسامحنا واختم يا ربنا بالصالحات
اعمالنا واغفر اللهم للجماعه الحاضرين
ووالدينا ووالديهم اجمعين والى من انشا
هذا المكان ومن عمل فيه لله من خير وبر
واحسان امين اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في
كل مكان امين اللهم الف بين قلوب المسلمين
في كل مكان اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا انك انت
التواب الرحيم اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى
المسلمين اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين
اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين اللهم
ارحم موتانا وموتى المسلمين ومن ماتوا على
التوحيد يا رب العالمين سبحان ربك رب
العزه عما يصفون وسلام سلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين ان الله يامر
بالعدل
والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن
الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك الله